remains from the downed Malaysian
Airlines flight are taken to a military
complex in Hilversum forensic
specialists are working to establish the
identities of the dead passengers and
hear Dutch people continue to lay down
flowers the entire nation is up in arms
over what seen as the shockingly slow
and disorderly investigation you can
evenly shouting off yeah take the Rings
off the victims fingers and steal their
bank cards this reminds me of nineteen
forty to forty-five the dead bodies
piled up in trucks images will never
forget don't you sure sure hope crucial
the sanctions against Russia should be
much more severe there should be
sanctions against Putin what Putin is
now doing is unjustifiable it's just
murder did Sean Morton the growing anger
in the Netherlands has found an outlet
in social media especially on Twitter
that's prompted a well-known journalist
in blogger Hans lado to analyze the
reactions of his fellow Dutch citizens
many tweets call for an immediate
military intervention your neighbors
could have been on the plane your nephew
grandparents and their grandchildren so
everybody was touched by it and in a way
hit by it so this brought out anger and
Twitter is an easy way to do it you just
pick up your phone or your your laptop
or whatever and you start tweeting
that's all you don't always need to
think first before you send out a
Twitter a tweet
thwaites included calls for Vladimir
Putin's daughter who has been living in
the Netherlands with her Dutch boyfriend
to be deported the mayor of Hilversum
even demanded that in a radio broadcast
but later apologized maria putin who
reportedly owns this penthouse left a
day after the plane came down according
to neighbors tweets about protests in
front of the house proved to be empty
threats as people realized the young
woman could hardly be responsible for
the disaster but the mood in the country
is that someone should be made
accountable that's important to the
families of the victims as an
organization that's helping many of them
193 Dutch citizens killed in a single
belligerent act it's a unique situation
for the Netherlands it makes a lot of
difference to the relatives who will be
finally held responsible for what has
happened there of course very much
interested in there in this they want to
know this as soon as possible and
difficult for them is that it will take
time maybe a lot of time until it
becomes totally clear who is responsible
the individual tragedies have dominated
media reports one of the victims was yo
F langga a distinguished aids researcher
and treatment pioneer his colleagues at
Amsterdam University expressed their
sorrow and dismay there he had a big
impact on me personally it was an
extraordinary person we were really as
they say I think standing on some one in
his shoulders suddenly these shoulders
are not there anymore so it's a big loss
lunga and a number of other passengers
were on their way to a major aids
conference in Melbourne their death has
been a huge blow for scientists and HIV
activists around the world
each day has brought more details to
light and that has increased the
pressure on the Dutch government to show
more backbone and demand tougher EU
sanctions against Russia there's another
task for the government also that to
explain to the people very clearly that
that is something that will have to be
shared at the national level and that
everybody may suffer a little bit for
that reason above all people in the
Netherlands want an investigation and
they want clarity as to who shot down
the plane I'm deal that they should be
extremely punished there is no other
solution we won't get the people back
anyway in this case we need to catch the
people who are responsible so that they
will never do it again that's the dock
naught minus the Netherlands has 17
million inhabitants and although not
everyone was personally acquainted with
one of the victims the feeling is that
everyone in the country has been touched
by the tragedy sign here we're here for
the people who died and for their
relatives but we're also here a little
bit for ourselves to prepare ourselves
it's because we're flying the same route
to sell if the water
the masses of flowers at amsterdam's
airport were supposed to be cleared away
now officials have decided to create a
permanent memorial as the public
expressions of sorrow and anger continue
unabated
you